le gouvernement de justin trudeau
présente donc jeudi son projet de loi
très attendue depuis les dernières
élections pour que le cannabis à usage
récréatif soit légalisé à partir du 1er
juillet 2018
ce qu'on ne sait pas c'est l'âge à
partir duquel on pourra consommer
légalement 18 ans 19 ans plusieurs
penchent pour les 19 ans qui constitue
l'âge où il est l'égal de boire dans la
plupart des provinces canadiennes mais
les provinces pour reda les provinces
peuvent aller plus haut
line beauchamp et criminologue à
l'université d'ottawa
pourquoi butin c'est que la
préoccupation majeure la config le
départ si on veut que le gouvernement
fédéral avait donné aux groupes de
travail
c'est je veux que les jeunes ne ferait
qu'un plus le marché noir pour aller
s'approvisionner ou envoient leur
proposer toutes sortes d'autres produits
et je veux des projets dans la qualité
est assurée contrôlez pas de promotion
alors ils sont partis avec ça alors si
on avait mis 25,1 par exemple comme âge
d'approvisionnement et on sait que près
de 40% des de la consommation est fait
par une cliente à la botte de 2,5 à
torreilles de marché dans un marché
illégal pour approvisionner un bovin
tracas et un autre marché règle itacaré
maintenu deux marches
la grande inconnue sera donc la réaction
des jeunes au nouveau système de
distribution de leurs drogues
récréatives favorite h mais si on
intervient tôt plus jeunes pour voir à
quel âge réellement les jeunes
commençaient encore une fois que les
drogues et pourquoi ils le faisaient
quelles étaient les raisons pour
lesquelles il le fait et myriam
laventure et professeur en
psychoéducation à l'université de
sherbrooke donc à une centaine de
kilomètres au sud-est de montréal
le cancer est ici c'est que on doit pas
commencer à s'intéresser à la
consommation uniquement à 14,15 même si
l'âge légal est établi à 18 ans est
clair que les jeunes s'initient à
l'alcool et aux drogues avant l'âge de
18 ans c'est sûr que va falloir qu'on
travaille de façon différente par
conséquent la même chose travailler par
de la prévention les destins sont
illégales vers ceux d'essence sont
légales quand on fait la prévention des
cigarettes ou de l'alcool qui sont deux
substances légales bien qu'elle soit à
80 pour le jeune c'est acceptable
puisque c'est légal donc là on va entrer
dans sa famille l'a également le
cannabis déjà pour les jeunes ce qu on
entend déjà sur le terrain des jeunes
cbc post grand parce que on voulait
légaliser et comme donc déjà qu'il fasse
cette association là il y aura un risque
en fait légale légaliser égalise pour
paul dargis pas de problème ait pas de
risque à consommer donc dans nos actions
préventives va falloir évidemment temps
d'aller dans les perceptions des jeunes
puis voir comment ils ont été repris
évidemment le fait que ça soit légal
donc je pense que ça va changer des
pratiques des jeunes ou du moins être
que ça va changer leur façon de motiver
leur consommation de tabac illégal donc
c'était les gars c'est que c'est pas
grave
malgré le fait qu' il y ait des risques
pour le développement des jeunes seront
tous ceux faut pas perdre de vue que la
prohibition n'a d'abord pas du tout
empêché les jeunes de confort est dans
le top 5 mondial
bon on a mal à ses très jeunes jean
sébastien fallu et professeur à l'école
de psychoéducation de l'université de
montréal et fondateur du groupe de
recherche et d'intervention
psychosociale grip mais aussi la
prohibition en elle-même est pas pour
rien que les kofi annan et louise arbour
de feu monde recommande d'aller gagner à
fort taux parce que c'est bon pour la
fin a rappelé ou capa drif c'est parce
que la prohibition en elle-même a des
conséquences d'une ampleur
incommensurables sur à peu près toutes
les femmes mais de la société en faire
et donc dans ce sens là oui il ya
peut-être des risques mais je trouve à
six responsables et médecin qui lui
donnons accès à 25 un bon 21 7 juin peut
plus rêver
mais il faut savoir que l'iq
consommateurs les plus grand nombre de
consommateurs surtout chez les 18 25 ans
et c'est complètement incohérent avec
l'accès à l'alcool qui est pourtant un
produit pour lequel on devrait beaucoup
plus se préoccuper parce que les
dommages sont beaucoup mieux documenter
beaucoup plus importants notamment sur
le cerveau déjà de les faire alors il ya
beaucoup d'incohérences
un reportage de radio canada
international